that has this like history of like crazy
experiences and now she's like you know
what I want to change I want like a real
guy I'm ready to be this woman that he
wants me to be what do you think is the
like
do I think it's possible do you think
it's possible I think it's possible that
it's not probable
and it depends when did she do it
because the more time you like were you
doing that for five years it's gonna
take you probably five years to turn it
off at least oh were you doing it for 10
if if I ate dessert every day for 10
years it wouldn't be hard to quit very
yeah and it's the same thing with that
so guys kind of look at okay how long
did you do it for when did you do it and
how bad was it oh it was an acceptable
age to stop kind of going out I mean I
wouldn't recommend like if you want to
be a wife if that's the outcome I
wouldn't recommend doing it at all but
you know this youngest you can't stop
especially that people who go to
university where it's like you have more
access and like there's no parental
that's when a lot of people do their
experimenting and that's when they say
like I went through my hose phase that's
so true you know what I'm saying that's
what a lot of people have their like
college experience where I was like I
haven't read them with this person was
like just random [__] because everyone's
just horny because your hormones are
like reading everyone just especially
when you've just lost it I feel like
because when I just lost my like sorry
if I'm if it's sensitive but when I just
lost my virginity it I just went
crazy like I've never felt this feeling
before and I want to feel it again
because it feels good you couldn't keep
doing it with the same guy
um you know what I tried to but then
this guy like he obviously I found out
that he was like playing and he just
wanted me for the uh yeah yeah so I was
like you know what I don't want you well
the the issue is you're you're gonna
you're gonna be so if you're sleeping
around casually usually girls sleep out
of their league yeah so you don't really
know what your league is until you look
at the guys that are willing to date you
yeah because you can guys
anything right I mean have you ever been
cheated on and you look at the girl he
cheated on you I mean don't be a person
but you've heard that right yeah guys
cheat with like I can't believe her yeah
yeah I feel like that's even worse
because it's like she's not even lame no
I would have understood if she was
language
yeah because it's if you're a girl
that's a five six seven right and you're
sleeping with an eight nine or ten
you're gonna get the guy that you
actually date and you're gonna miss the
guy from before and I'm sure you've seen
that with maybe a friend or something
where they're dating one guy but they
miss the old one and that's the problem
you get when you've had more and more
Partners is like how how is the guy
that's going to take you seriously going
to compare well she need like what about
like the phrase try before you buy like
if you even buy like a product you'll
look up reviews see how it looks so much
see because especially as a woman you
need to kind of know what you like I
guess because I know I didn't say like
wait till you're married but I you know
um I think women kind of act dumb like
they can't tell who's taking them
seriously and who's not and when you
really ask questions like did he take
you on a date did he do this did he do
that and you really peel back delay
I don't know sometimes sometimes in life
you're gonna take L's right and there's
gonna be guys that bamboozle you but the
majority of guys it's pretty easy to
tell if you and most guys will tell you
if you ask them it's true I mean that's
an inward thing though because you've
got a kind of I think certain women are
afraid of being alone and that's why
they kind of are like serial dancers
like serial datas and they can't like be
by themselves that's why I do think it's
good for women to be single for like at
least a year so you understand like the
kind of piece it gives you because
otherwise all you know is relationships
of course you're going to stay in a bad
relationship and especially now that
people want romance so badly do you
think a man that's looking for a wife
wants a girl that's at peace being alone
I think yeah because he knows that she's
like a good she doesn't need to be out
there all the time like she can be her
own person
but they always say but like don't they
say like you're [__] you'll find your
perfect guy when you least expect it so
if you're minding your business and you
can't you're not like what is marriage
I don't know I'm young I can't so two
two plus two it's there's some phrase
it's like too flush become one so it's
like two become one right and so if a
guy's looking for a wife why would he
want a girl that's okay being alone when
he wants to be with her forever
because she you can be with somebody but
also being able to have peace and not be
like dependent like oh you're my husband
I need to do everything with you though
this is like this is why this is why
like women have no idea what men want
they want a girl that's clingy the only
time the guys don't like girls that are
clingy that they don't like
but think about the last guy that's
really chased you or been into you do
you think he would have cared if you
were clingy no no he would have liked
because I'm literally experiencing him
like what you're saying right now so I'm
like but you guys everything it's
actually true everything everything
you're saying is from like a feminine
point of view because we don't like men
that are clingy
so you put up like you made you think
that's what men want that's not true
we'll never know because we're not beds
I could never say it's like I could ask
men I've asked my guy I have a lot of
like really great guy friends and I'm
kind of awesome like am I intimidating
like why do you guys not want to date me
and it's like I said no it's just weird
and just I would rather be at peace than
just be in my face and just be like just
like oh this is a lot what are the what
do the guys say when you say am I
intimidating what are they say they say
that I can come off intimidating due to
my job and like like I've had people
think that I've been a [__] before just
because I'm confident I'm kind of like
quite direct because usually like I will
flirt with guys or if they flirt with me
because I haven't been like taken out in
a long time I don't I can't read the
signals probably so I think they're just
being friendly back and then it's like
oh you played that guy I'm like what I'm
just being nice like and so I think what
they've said is I need to learn to like
be a bit more
so I'll miss it so to speak so I'm it's
true I'm trying but I think it's I I
think once you've been hurt so many
times it's hard to submit because a lot
of women submit and get hurt so it's
like what's the point of doing that if
this outcome is going to be the same who
are who are they submitting to who are
they picking to submit to
food for you guys
yeah and then whose fault is that yeah I
guess but what about like when you meet
a guy and he he's so nice at the start
and you think like oh my God could this
be the one and then you submit and then
he's an also afterwards is that typical
yeah you think I mean I haven't you
think men switch up completely well not
completely but like enough because once
questions
so I'm in a really good it's okay I
think some of them are good because like
you said they'll do anything and say
anything and if you're not experienced
enough in the dating world like you're
just coming into so say you're like 16
as some older guys like yeah I'll take
you out I'll buy you flowers and you're
thinking
and then he's just an [__] also he's
like what happened and I feel like at
that age at 16 we still think your brain
hasn't even before another question is
how long did you wait to sleep with him
and not not you but like like in general
right because it's like if you're
sleeping with them right away
what does that tell you yeah because
women I feel like women sometimes use
sex to kind of keep the mind because
they know that's what men want so it's
not necessarily that you would like to
but because you like him so much are
like I'll give you whatever this is what
I can do to to make him stay and that's
an actual submission that's yeah it's
kind of upsetting that you said what's
your job again you're an influencer
I'm a like presenter and I do content
for me and other brands yeah um I think
marketing yourself on the internet where
you're flirting with other guys is gonna
I don't flip no that's what you that's
what you said before you said when
you're doing interviews you're like
flirting with guys oh no not in my
interviews oh my God oh my God okay oh
my God no I'm like oh my God no okay
okay yeah no I'm just like if I'm at an
industry event oh my gosh oh okay okay
um man and I'll say this is someone with
a big following it doesn't help really
no I don't think it helps at all it's
actually kind of a negative like men
prefer girls that aren't low-key no I I
get that and that's the thing that's
that's why I've struggled a lot as well
and but it's hard because it's like you
can try and date someone within the
industry but then it's like some
sometimes it can be a competition thing
or like they want someone who's at home
but then if you're marrying someone who
let's just say is like an accountant
like it really could work like a bang
and has a really cool job but you're
gonna be like flying because I fly out
places and he's at home and I'm thinking
oh it's kind of peak on him what kind of
guy do you want
I don't know anymore I haven't met like
do you know you're 21. I'm 21. I've not
been out there long enough and I've been
single for a really long time but it's
like
just someone who's can show me things
that I can't show myself I would say and
someone who can like take control and
even if I am working can still like have
my back and cheer me on and not be
jealous of it
okay like oh so so not jealous please
how's your back do you want to work do
you want to stay home what do you want
to do I want to work as long as I can to
like I mean I want to work to a point
where I've made my money and I'm known
enough in the industry that I can still
do jobs here and there but then be able
to just like just chill like when I hit
like about like 30 just when you'll be
able to chill so like work work work
chill out okay
um when do you want to have kids
not until I'm like late late 20s but
like days okay so 30s when does when
does geriatric pregnancy start I don't
know what that well then when when does
it when does it become more increasingly
high risk to have a child
that's like a letter phase
women be popping out babies at 40 like
you know what they don't show you the
the women that didn't pop out babies at
40 and that tried
it's not you don't have I mean you're 21
so you have time yeah but geriatric
pregnancy starts at 35 and half your
eggs are gone by 30. wow so you know
you know people can have kids and do the
career thing later
it's true but with my line of work I
would say I can't necessarily like it's
like if you're a model it's like you
only have when you're young yeah yeah
you can do it for a sec even like
athletes you have to do it in your kind
of prime so that afterwards you're like
good enough which is which is fine but
you know it's just a trade-off because
it's going to be unattractive to the men
you want well to have a kid afterwards
no to well to be older a girl that's in
the industry that's been around industry
men for 10 years like so let's say you
get married at 30 right you're gonna
have been around these high value men
for 10 years right because you're around
all the celebrities you'll probably have
hooked up with a couple by then
just I mean come on you're gonna you're
gonna be around them for 10 years
nothing you're not gonna go on a date
nothing so you're gonna hit 30 right
you're gonna been around these men for
10 years and
you know you have a whole big social
media following it's like that's going
to be unattractive too and if you make a
lot of money the guys you want it's
going to be a small percentage because
you're going to want someone that makes
more money than you yeah but I think you
should be allowed to date someone within
that realm you shouldn't be looking no I
I think you're allowed to but I just
think what what percent of guys do you
think make six figures I know it's not a
lot but you don't have to make six
figures to be comfortable
how much do you need to be comfortable
it depends where you live okay how much
where do you want to live like between
here and like I would say
I love New York in like Miami okay so in
a big city how much do you need to be
comfortable
like holidays six biggest mountains
I like big kids with kids oh with kids
oh how much money do you need seven
things well combined or individually
um how much combined combined I would
say like if you're both on a good salary
of at least like
Maybe
like at least like 50k enough okay so
100K total is a household yeah I guess
and if you aren't gonna work you'd have
to make what
yeah but I'm just telling you that the
older you are you're gonna be uglier
black don't crack so I don't know that
because I'm I'm basically like a lot of
women that I know who are like of the
same it doesn't mean you'll probably
look better than say white women at 30
right but
you're still gonna be uglier than you
are now I'll say uglia I'll say more
season but I'm telling you how men see
it is less attractive but then let's
attractive so like half of them are bold
they're like I'll tell you I'll tell you
that's not true that's not true so man
if you look at dating app swipes women
half of um by the time when you start at
18 to when you're 30 your swipes go down
by 50
where men they just go up
because women we look at other things
like their job if they're funny if all
this stuff and they get funnier over
time they get the younger women on us
will still date the 40 or at least look
at the 45 year old where the it's not
the same for men We're Men around our
age at like 30 35 they start dating
younger and younger that's just weird
though I feel like men who date younger
can't don't have the capability of
dating women their own age why why would
they date someone their own age when
they could date younger so if not even
with women if men like girls with low
body counts if they like young
attractive women that can bear that can
have kids for them why would they want
to date someone their own age because
it's like what do you have in common
with like if a 30 year old came to me as
like what do we have do you think men
care that much about what they have in
common with a girl
at some point in their life yes because
you see a lot of men who date these
pretty modern women it gets to a point
where they're like oh yeah she's pretty
but what else is she bringing like can
we have a conversation do you think that
rich men that have the most options
don't date model of women they model
women but I don't I think deep down
inside everyone wants someone they can
actually like talk to you and I think
like they realize that's why a lot of
them eating men do you think men value
talking to their women
I think if you're an intelligent man
then yes do you think that men want to
talk all the time not all the time but
at least if you're out to dinner if I'm
just there like oh my God hey guys like
just on my phone what's more important
to men looks or talking
intellectual man talking
foreign
you think okay so you think that Jeff
Bezos do you think he's an intellectual
man yes do you think that Leonardo
DiCaprio is an intellectual man yeah
okay Leonardo do you think about Drake's
do you think Drake's an intellectual man
yeah I know okay two out of the three of
them date like 22 year olds 25 year olds
very true they all date younger but the
cereal day is they can't stay in a
relationship and that just goes to
previous point where you are unable to
sustain something because you're dating
women who you are just getting for four
looks that's that's nothing that's just
do you think they want to stand what
incentive do men have to stay in
relationships to have a family
good mother that you know is like these
are my children these are like your
these are parts of you like why would
you not want someone great to raise your
kids so it's interesting I used to have
that thought right and I never
understood why men would want to be
alone okay I used to think that and what
I realized is so if if you let's say you
became a millionaire okay and you
decided to have a child with with a guy
okay and if that guy who let's say he
changed his mind all the time every day
he was in out I don't know like just a
bunch of different whatever and he had
the power to leave at any point
90 chance he he takes the kid with him
and he's gonna take 50 to 80 percent of
all the money you made
would you sign up for that no prenup
so prenups aren't legally binding here
and what they're not legally binding
here no
no that's crazy well I'm a U.S citizen
so I'll get married in America so so
prenups in the US it depends on the
state
but the 50 50 the kids so you can
protect your assets more in a prenup but
when it comes to children
and child support
an alimony so men don't have a lot of
incentive to us you're an American
citizer where are you from yeah like all
my families well like my dad's from New
York and all my family live in Florida
I'm in Chicago but but yeah there's just
not as much incentive nowadays
that's because I don't think there's
been a lot of people who have had happy
marriages like you don't really look
around and see that so why which and
even as a woman I as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible